jugé ringard plan-plan pas très
confortable il ya encore peu le camping
fait un retour en force déjà 5 % de
réservations plus pour cet été nous
sommes douze millions à planter la tente
chaque année la sortie du film camping 2
n'y est pas pour rien dans cet effet de
mode
aujourd'hui on peut trouver en france
des campings incroyable pour un peu on
se croirait sous les tropiques en plein
désert ou carrément revenue au bon vieux
temps du far west
il va falloir s'y faire le cliché slip
moulant bob et pâtissent c'est vraiment
des passifs dans le bassin d'arcachon
c'est l'étape incontournable
l'ascension de la dune du pilat mais
maintenant on vient aussi ici pour ça le
camping des flots bleus
c'est ici que les films aux 10 millions
de spectateurs camping 1 et 2 ont été
tournées patrick et ce bac
depuis c'est le défilé permanent
tout le monde veut sa photo souvenir
dans la peau de franck dubosc alias
patrick chirac
l'autre jour il y avait même un quart de
deux militaires ils se sont tous arrêtés
et tout le cas sont descendus pour faire
prendre en photo devant le panneau
bernadette c'est la nouvelle directrice
du camping
il n'en revient toujours pas faire un
petit point sur les réservations
quand le film est sorti au cinéma il ya
trois semaines les derniers emplacements
pour cet été se sont littéralement
arrachée elle voir ils veulent vivre et
nous demandent de l'emplacement 17 la
tante de patrick chirac
ils sont très très attiré par par
l'effet fine ce week end il n'y a plus
un mobile home de libre pour jouer à
fond sur l'effet camping de bernadette a
eu une idée
elle a conservé tous les décors du film
et en plus ça ne lui a rien coûté
nous avons demandé la production s'il
était possible de conserver les décors
ils nous ont laissé tout ça bien
volontiers et partout où les scènes
cultes ont été tournées c'est pareil
vous avez la pergola qui était
construite pour le film à la terrasse du
restaurant avec nous avons gardé le
sigle de pizzeria chez mario le croquis
également sa du parti car patrick tu
m'as compris si tu veux chasser la
guerre reste à côté du pot de miel salut
patrick mais pas question de s'arrêter
au décor cet été même les animations
seront inspirés du film
bernadette a engagé des professionnels
exprès est ce que votre équipe a préparé
quelque chose d des soirées dans les
thèmes du dans le thème du film et on ne
fait pas à bernadette les animateurs ont
intérêt être incollable ils ont ils ont
vu le film mais je pense qu'il faut où
il faut jouer à fond la carte du film la
plupart des gens qui sont là aujourd'hui
on n'a qu'à regarder par la fenêtre
il ya des fous de gens qui s'arrêtent
prendre des photos au site suisse et
daterait du film avant tout
s'il y en a bien qui a tout compris
c'est didier l'épicier du camping dans
sa boutique la moitié de la place est
envahie par les produits dérivés du film
lampe de poche sac de plage autocollant
est le numéro un des ventes
le t-shirt avec la réplique culte du
film
tous les jours on en vend 20 30 40 à peu
près ses articles ses 50% de sa recette
incroyable cette comédie est en passe de
devenir un vrai phénomène
la famille d'arreau par exemple ça
faisait plus de dix ans qu'elle n'avait
pas mis les pieds dans un camping en
sortant du cinéma
l'envié est revenue illico arrêté
pendant des années je sais pas pourquoi
cette opération ces films là font que
ben ça serait ça revient au goût du jour
ses retombées économiques gilbert
cordier les avait vus venir avant tout
le monde
cet ancien vendeur de voitures a racheté
le camping juste avant le tournage du
film grâce à la sortie en salles son
chiffre d'affaires devrait faire un bond
de 50%
c'est à peu près à trois millions cinq
sur les périodes je pense que cette
année devrait être une très bonne année
à le film à jouer bonjour ce film c'est
la poule aux oeufs d'or pour le camping
de gilbert mais vous allez voir que
celui à qui il a racheté n'est pas à
plaindre non plus mais aussi dans les
landes à 50 km de biscarrosse c'est
claude dagréou l'ancien propriétaire des
flots bleus
aujourd'hui il tient toujours un camping
mais celui-ci ne marchait pas du tout
car il ne répondait pas aux trois
critères du bon camping
le premier c'est la situation le
deuxième c'est la situation la troisième
si la situation et nous ici on a tout
faux on n'est pas au bord de l'océan
n'est pas bord de laquelle n'est pas
mort heures de route passante
donc il fallait quand se démarque
c'était un camping on peut plus
classique
résultat pas un chat alors claude à
changer de latitude ce n'est pas lié les
bananiers il a fait sortir de terre le
signale un village tropical au beau
milieu des landes
il a tout misé sur le camping à thème la
mer et à une douzaine de kilomètres qu'à
cela ne tienne leur nouvelle piscine
ressemblera un lagon de 7000 m² monsieur
le maire n'en croit pas ses yeux suisse
coach pour ce petit bout de plage à
demeure
les époux dagréou ont fait venir deux
mille tonnes de sable blanc planté 200
bananier une soixantaine de pamiers ça
va lui coûter une petite fortune
combien il a coûté je sais pas on va
faire le point
à la ferme 350 évidence 350000 euros la
facture pourrait même avoisiner les 500
mille euros
au final si claude et françois se sont
lancés dans ce projet pharaonique
c'est parce que ça fait venir du monde
22 au 29 mai là on prouve bien qu'on est
à 90 % de réservations et surtout en
revendant le camping des flots bleus
ils ont réalisé une super affaire
souvenir il l'aurait revendu 5 millions
d'euros
comme c'était juste après la sortie du
film le prix avait bien sûr été revu à
la hausse les chiffres on va dire un
truc 15e pour ça soa tenez vous bien un
petit million d'euros en plus haut -
claude a de quoi payer sa facture d'eau
quand il devra remplir son petit bout
d'océan
mais vous allez voir qu'il existe des
campings encore plus fou
il était une fois dans le sud-ouest un
camping très différents le far west à
une heure de bordeaux
celui qui est parti à la conquête d'un
nouveau genre de camping c'est arnaud il
a eu l'idée il ya dix ans quand la
tempête du siècle a dévasté tout ces
installations 27 décembre 99 et bien en
l'espace de six heures 2000 pinson 2000
arbres sont tombés
voilà entraînant dans leur chute les
routes les toitures les réseaux et donc
une destruction à 100% nous avons été
l'établissement le plus touché
d'aquitaine comme vous avez le terrain
qui ressemble avec un ensemble de tuteur
au parking d'auchan
mais vous vous dites qu'il faut
absolument vendre autre chose
arnaud venais juste de racheter le
camping avec un crédit de 700 mille
euros sur le dos il commence à tout
reconstruire
seul comme un pionnier d'amérique nous
rentrons la sueur droite de maastricht
donc l'entrée vous avez d'abord le
saloon le restaurant à droite / gauche
qui donne directement sur l'accueil
c'est ce qu'on appelle le dance hall
c'est là où on fait tout ce qui est dans
ce cours de danse country
arnaud s'est immédiatement positionné
sur un créneau porteur
le camping de luxe 16 hectares pour 900
personnes les mobil homes sont flambant
neuf
ici c'est 800 euros la semaine il n'y a
qu'une chose qui lui manque pour devenir
un camping cinq étoiles
ce sont des sanitaires supplémentaires
ce sera bientôt chose faite
dans ce décor d'école tout droit sortie
de la petite maison dans la prairie
leur bloc sanitaire comme celui ci coûte
très cher au moins 35 % de plus que ce
que mes collègues peut mettre en place
on est ici sur une facture à 400000
euros
mais le village western c'est plus que
de l'argent c'est un concept quitte à
casser le mythe
ici pas de miss camping pas de
discothèques pathé pas de tour de france
pas de pastis etc etc etc
oui c'est à tout un catalogue
d'activités à faire pâlir n'importe quel
centre aéré équitation western
initiation à l'artisanat amérindien
cours de l'assaut arnaud propose une
quarantaine d'animations autour des
cowboys et des indiens
il a même créé une rivière artificielle
pour apprentis chercheurs d'or
ça me calme si en plus on peut trouver
des paillettes d'or et pour que ces
campeurs ne repartent pas bredouille
unis versent chaque été dit grammes d'or
du coup c'est toujours plein et voici sa
dernière attraction un authentique
campement indien avec ses tipis
traditionnels pour le montage en
revanche il a pris quelques libertés
j'aimerais qu'on est loin de là
de la technique ancestrale utilisée par
les secours pour dresser le tipi pendant
que l'entrée homme était à la chasse
arnoux en acheter une douzaine 5000
euros pièce bref c'est trois fois moins
cher qu'un mobile home à l'achat et en
plus c'est deux fois plus rentable
ils les louent 600 euros la semaine
trente mètres carrés avec tout le
confort moderne
qui a dit que dormir sous une tente
c'était pas du luxe